well thank you for having me like Jesse
said I'm gonna talk about graphical
tooling what's possible today a little
bit about what's possible in your future
and then some long term ideas but
primarily I want to focus on like the
reason that you actually care about all
of this is that you want to accelerate
adoption of your api's right you build
these api's you put your blood your
sweat and your tears into them and it's
heartbreaking if people don't end up
using them and I think a good way to get
people to use them is to make sure that
every step along the way of using your
API is a joyous one so a quick
background about me Sean coming out of
San Francisco I work at a company called
one graph we'll talk a little bit about
that today but in a previous life I ran
engineering for a payments company and
my personal background is I worked a lot
enclosure enclosure script work a lot on
the compiler for that these days I tend
to live in a reason and rust world but
for the past decade or so I've worked
pretty focused on dev tooling so much so
that it's a very near and dear to my
heart and bad dev tooling makes me very
sad so today I want to talk about first
of all why should we care at all about
the graphical tooling and possibilities
and whatnot in order to set up context
because the meat of this is going to be
a lot of rapid-fire demos and ideas
across the whole spectrum of graph QL
and I realize it's the last talk of the
day so it's going to be a little bit
hard to keep up potentially so I want to
set that frame and then I want talk a
little bit about the future about what's
possible so let's start with why we
would actually care I think there are
two things to keep in mind about your
API in particular around adoption and
that is that content is king and
competition is fierce for any given API
the two things I actually care about are
what data does it have that I care about
and what can it do on my behalf what
effects can it achieve that is going to
actually help me achieve my business
goal and this is important because we've
actually talked to a lot of API
companies and it turns out that for any
like on average for
any of these API companies that we
talked to about 20% of their business
deals are actually blocked on an
integration phase because what happens
is they have good content or they
provide good effects for a business and
someone in the business sides decides to
spend money on it expecting that the
integration phase is going to go
relatively smoothly what happens is upon
proving the value of the API the
integration phase actually ends up
taking so many engineering are so much
in terms of engineering resources that
the business person actually has to get
a schedule on the engineering resource
roadmap right and these are engineers
who are trying to actually ship product
not integrate your API so whenever we
look at API integrations there are two
factors that I tend to think about one
is what is the absolute amount of energy
required to successfully integrate your
API from understanding what it has to
offer to reading through the
documentation to successfully
integrating and running monitoring all
that sort of stuff so that's kind of the
the cost of integration the other side
of that is the intrinsic motivation so
how happy is it going to make me as a
developer to actually spend time on this
I think all of us have spent time
dealing with api's that made us deeply
sad as human beings and that those kind
of integrations take a lot longer to
finish and so if your company is
offering an API that makes people sad it
is going to take them longer to finish
it's going to be more difficult to
actually push those deals through and
the set thing is that api's are rarely
known for sparking joy right we can
actually name the the companies that do
API is very well off the top of our
heads because there are so few examples
of people who have trail blazed in this
area and I think that's for a couple
different reasons some of it is maybe
ivory tower design where you have people
who design the API are very far removed
and people actually end up using it and
there's a lack of empathy there they're
it's hard to understand what people are
looking for an API but I think far more
common is just simply a lack of
resources whenever you're building out
an API
you typically want to spend time in your
domain model right you've thought about
you have a business you have a product
and you're modeling on an API that
matches that but in addition to that to
actually deliver a good developer
experience you need to build out a bunch
of documentation and design tools and
monitoring and so on and so forth and
it's very difficult to actually amortize
this right the companies that do this
very very well have actually invested a
lot in here but that's not a luxury that
all of us get to enjoy and I think it's
good to bring up maybe a typical story
because the people who implements api's
and the people who adopt api's typically
see things very differently as an API
provider this is oftentimes how I view
my API I kind of figured that a user
success just increases linearly with the
more time they they spend right that's
4x Ament X minutes spent reading my
documentation and hitting my endpoints
the user is going to be Y successful but
in reality we've actually seen something
much more like a sawtooth bridge where
you know maybe step 1 is I have to find
your Google for your your API Docs and I
find them and then I have to kind of
parse them because you've invented your
own documentation system which is
beautiful and lovely but it's different
from everyone else's I have to figure
out where in the in pipe or where in the
API actually has the data that I care
about I have to kind of maybe visually
guess what is the data gonna look like
when it comes back I'll finally maybe
test this out maybe with curl or
something on those lines having gotten
some data back I'll have to figure out
why it wasn't didn't look like it did in
the docs having actually got some data
back now I wanted to move that into a
useful context like building my app or
something like that now I have to like
try to remember back in like what were
the fields that were coming in there and
ultimately the only reason I'm heating
your API is to pull down data to
integrate with my my local data right so
I actually have to bridge that and
figure out how to get your data to work
with mine and then I'm good to go
right so I've worked my way all the way
through here just in time for you to
release version 2 and I'll start over
and this is actually a kind of generous
view because not all of
v-steps are equal some of these steps
will cause a much bigger drain on a
developer's resource or energy level
than others in particular off we see
that whenever a developer has to
implement a custom oil flow or what not
to hit your API in a production way
they'll typically lose up to like half
an hour or an hour easily and the reason
for all these kind of drop-off in
productivity or dropping out of flow
there are a couple different ones but
you know some of it is because of the ad
hoc learning that I have to kind of
figure out how you do your own special
snowflake documentation some of it is
I'm shifting between documentation and
my code and kind of a testing
environment some of it is I have to
recall what your documentation said
versus what I'm actually sitting in my
code and it's kind of crazy because as
developers write as API providers we're
aware of the misconceptions that other
people have about our productivity very
often a non developer will approach us
and think well I'll just grab five
minutes of their time and we'll chat
about this thing and then they'll be the
developer will be productive right away
and we know that it's actually it takes
time to recover once you've been knocked
out of flow it takes time to recover and
get back into that state of flow every
time you're interrupted and as an API
provider you should be very concerned
about this because every time I get
knocked out of my flow I don't feel
happy and I'm going to actually start
thinking about other things so these are
actually tab competition points that's
where your tab is in my browser but it's
sitting next to literally the best sites
on the internet that are engineered to
grab my attention any time I'm feeling
bad so for every API you want to kind of
there are three criteria that you want
to look for so in particular it's the
time to initial success so from me
learning of your API to actually feeling
like I have some success with your API
that needs to be as short as possible
the second is the intensity of the
success how much of a superhero did you
make me feel like wow how amazed do I
feel about what I was able to achieve
with your API in such a short amount of
time
and then finally having made me
successful what is the next time I'm
going to feel successful so for example
if I'm in your documentation and I'm
able to run some example in points and I
see data coming back that's great that's
a huge success
but if it then takes me an hour to
properly implement all of the off and
get that into my code then that's a long
time without any sort of success so you
can just translate these criteria into
Maxim's for any API design one of the
first which is deliver the quickest
initial success possible maximize the
wow factor and make sure that every step
along the way the user is in a constant
state of success that they feel
successful and not disappointed with
your API and I think graph QL helps
hugely here it is first and foremost
inherently machine readable by virtue of
construction every graphical server
isn't respectable by another computer
all right we can ask that graph QL
server say hey what types do you have
available what objects do you have what
fields you have what is the description
of them what are the types is it
knowable and that and of itself is okay
but what it enables in terms of shared
tooling for the ecosystem is huge we can
actually build tools that will
introspect any graph QL server and will
generate some pretty amazing experiences
and based off of that tooling that
enables us to build better and better
graphical servers which in turn enable
us to build better tooling so that's
kind of the preface that's setting up
the why we care and why graph QL might
be able to help us out here and so what
I'm gonna do now is dive into just a
bunch of demos and kind of show you from
the may be mundane for some of you who
are experienced with it to some of the
esoteric demos so first of all I want to
start with an oldie but a goodie
graphical so this is graphical this is
one of the original killer apps of graph
QL so you can point this at any API any
graphical server and you can get kind of
Auto
complete alright so we can just kind of
autocomplete our way through an API if
I'm not sure of any of the fields I can
just kind of click my way through here
and I kind of almost accidentally end up
building a query so this is pretty nice
that was certainly a demo that won me
over I think back in 2015 when I first
saw this because that is such an
incredibly different experience than
what was out there before you can do
some of that with the rest some of that
with you know swagger and whatnot but
this looks like a pretty interesting
tool at the time the thing is this is
actually I think almost bad for the
graph QL ecosystem because one of the
things that happens once you figure out
graph QL and you fall in love with it
you are almost by definition unable to
explain why it is good and you are
unable to empathize with people who
haven't learned it yet so I work at one
graph like I said one graph the idea is
very simple it's a single API endpoint
through which you get access to
Salesforce and stripe and QuickBooks and
NPM and whatnot and we started when
graph UO was fairly young I mean graffia
was still fairly young but when it was
even younger and so we had people who
did not know graph queue up they sign up
for one graph to get access to their
data and what happened was oh listen
all right so we had people who signed up
because I heard you know one graph can
get access to whatever very easily and
they actually thought that graph QL was
our own proprietary language and they're
like yeah this is cool but do you really
expect people to be able to learn your
own language just to give you a sense of
how much customer education is required
if you are building a graph queue API
and the thing with the graphical was we
thought we just put it in there and
people would figure out the magical
keystroke of control space and they be
able to autocomplete their way through
our API right it's a self documenting
API it's beautifully designed they're
gonna have no problem but we found is
that graphical is a blank canvas
and if you look at the syntax it's
actually I mean for us it looks alright
but for someone who doesn't know graph
QL it's incredibly intimidating so a
blank canvas combined with needing to
know how the syntax works was a big deal
so we built the graphic you'll explore
our graphical Explorer and the idea here
was to help onboard new users to graph
QL and so this is a plugin that works
with any graphical instance and it just
kind of visualizes your schema almost
like a file explorer so I can come in
here and say maybe I want to explore
Spotify and I see a search and notice
how it automatically focuses the query
because it says it knows that that's a
required argument so I'm going to search
for a query and any tracks that match
that I'm gonna get their ID and their
name and I'll go ahead and run that they
log in to Spotify real quick and there
we go so I'm able to kind of visually go
through and let's call this one search
so I'm able to go through visually an
exploring API and as I express I can
express the data that I want over here
and I can see the syntax build up on the
right-hand side so this gives me a way
of building up almost like a muscle
memory of saying all right if I want
this this is what it looks like over
here and it gives away it kind of
smooths the transition right where a lot
of the investment in the graphical
ecosystem was focused on people who were
already experts in graph QL a lot of
people were getting stuck at the blank
canvas stage and so we really wanted to
help smooth this out so this is a tool
that can be plugged in and will work
with any graph QL server and actually as
a quick side note I originally or we
originally built that for newcomers but
I found that it is by far my favorite
way of building things and we don't
mention it anywhere but if you have used
this here is a secret if you hold an
option it will actually select all of
the fields available at any given level
so that's uh we don't do that because
you shouldn't be doing that and everyone
asked for it but
you're a power user and you know what
you're doing then you can go ahead and
do that alright so we helped users
figure out the data that they want they
can express their intent they see a
graphical query coming up and then they
go ahead and get some results back so
I'm going to copy this over here now the
challenge is this is actually not a
useful context this is great for
exploring an API and experimenting
seeing what's available getting some
initial data back but no one or it's
very rare that this is actually the end
goal the only reason you come to
graphical is to figure out the query you
need to put somewhere else probably
inside of some app of some sort and so
what we want to do is figure out how we
can help you get it out of this context
and into a more useful context as
smoothly as possible
just like the graphical Explorer helped
onboard you we wanted to help or figure
out how to get you between a result and
to a working app as smoothly as possible
and so what we did is we built this tool
that actually analyzes the ast of your
graph QL query and it will generate a
full application and the first one that
we built so this was a little pet
project of mine is it will actually
analyze the ast and export it to a bash
program because who doesn't want to use
graph QL in bash so over here I have two
operations one is a query that's going
to get some information given an NPM
package name it'll get the number of
downloads last month and the other one
is going to pull an RSS feed Biograph
Kewell and so i'm going to copy this and
I'm going to go ahead and just paste
this in will chmod that and now whenever
I run this you can see it says hey here
are the two operations available so it
analyzed those operations inside of the
graphical explore and so I'll say well I
want to run the NPM one and I'll provide
some variables here and so we'll see how
many times the graphical package was
downloaded last month and let's pass
that into JQ and there we go so we can
see that the thank you so we can see
that the graphical package was
downloaded two or three times last month
and then I really like this one so I'm
going to come in here and copy an RSS
link same idea
so we'll do RSS URL we'll paste that in
and there we go now we have a JSON based
RSS reader inside of graph QL or inside
of bash that said I assume that most of
us are not using bash too that often so
what we do is build up a different one
real quick so I'm gonna go back and add
a search so same ideas before so we'll
do search Spotify win win win and any
tracks ID and their name and now I'm
gonna add a mutation and this one is
gonna be pause this is gonna go into
Spotify and I see all the options that
are available so I'm going to run the
pause mutation and this is going to
reach out and modify the state of my
Spotify player and having posit is going
to get in return me the new state so I
want to know are you playing and what's
your progress he'll add two more one of
which is resumed so same idea Spotify or
resume is playing in progress and then
the last one will be next so Spotify
skip next track and is playing progress
okay so now what we want to do is
actually instead of a bash let's go
ahead and look at the JavaScript and you
can see here that we've analyzed the
operations and we've done the same thing
where we're actually generating a rack
component for each of these operations
and like I said we have a lot of users
who have never used graph QL before so
our view on this world is a little bit
different and we see a lot of bad frog
in particular we see people who don't
know that you can name operations or use
variables so what they do is instead of
using variables they actually
concatenate strings at runtime and then
send those over as a way of kind of
interpolating their variables and so
what we tried to do is we try to analyze
the query and provide best practices so
you can see here I haven't named this
operation so in the code it's named it
unnamed query and it says hey maybe you
should consider giving this a name there
are all sorts of benefits if you do and
if I come back and over here and I give
it a name that goes away so the idea is
we don't block you at any step along the
way but we gently guide you towards the
best practices and now what I'm going to
do is this looks like it's working so
I'm going to go ahead and I could copy
and paste this but I'm just gonna hit
create sandbox so this is going to
create a new react application over here
and you'll notice that off has been
embedded in here as a provider of this
API I know how you should be doing
authentication inside of our API so I've
already generated that so now I'm making
live queries in a react application and
now I'm going to go ahead and let me
make this give this side-by-side with a
Spotify player and what I'm gonna do is
start playing whoops and I'm gonna hit
pause you notice it pauses I'm gonna
resume next and you'll notice that I
built an entire Spotify controller a
whole react application just by visually
exploring the API building up the
operations I want it and then generating
a react application with all of the best
practices embedded and the reason that
that's so important is because when
someone is trying to adopt your API they
are desperate for success they're
desperate to translate the API
documentation to a working app and what
that means is that they are going to
cobble together whatever they
and to get a working thing so they're
gonna get the minimum amount of code
together so they can actually call your
API and it's unlikely to include all of
the best practices that you would want
as an API provider that's going to make
both your life and their life better so
then what's going to happen is they
might leave a comment saying hey come
back later and fix this but they
probably won't and the next time that
someone wants to use your API they're
gonna search for the easiest thing which
is to go find the example that already
works they're going to copy and paste
that and any bad practices are now going
to spread through their code so what you
want to do as an API provider is to make
the right thing the easiest thing and
copying and pasting is by far the
easiest thing and so that's where you
want to have something like the code
exporter where you can make it very very
easy to consume your API with best
practices so you don't cause me to have
to think about how to use it so next
level would be Auto parametrizing
queries so I mentioned that we see a lot
of people who don't know about variables
variables are actually kind of an
esoteric part of graph QL and so what we
want to do is actually kind of Auto
parameterize the queries and the way
we're going to do this is inside of the
Explorer we're gonna have a little icon
that you whenever you hover over a
argument and whenever you click on the
icon to parameterize it it's going to
reflect on the field type and say all
right password is a required string it's
a non knowable string and then it's
going to replace the hard-coded value
that you have in there and it's going to
insert it as a variable dependency so we
end up with something like this where
we've turned it into a variable and then
we've created the the default value here
and let me show you what that looks like
in practice so you can see here I'm
about on building a signup form and it's
parametrized by a lot of different
things and so what I'm going to do is
Clark coming in here and say well I want
to
about a billion and if I right-click on
it in this case I'm just right-clicking
to parameterize it it will actually
parameterize it and it'll go back and
forth so if I don't want that to be a
parameter it won't be and then down here
it's actually building up a form that my
user would actually see what is this
actually going to look like for the end
user who's trying to consume this so you
can see I have a full signup form down
here that it can come in and start
experimenting with and get real-time
feedback on is this form doing exactly
what I expect it to be doing and it's
using all these nice best practices
where all of the variables are properly
parameterised rather than concatenate
increased rings and sending that up to
the server so we're calling that smart
forms it's not open source yet but we
will get there and I want to compare
this to existing experiences so we
played with a Spotify API and Spotify
actually has a great rest API it is
really really well documented but
because the REST API is so difficult to
introspect that means that the tooling
is really hard to share that means that
all of the tooling that they've built
they've basically built themselves or
bought from some vendor and that means
that the depth that they're able to go
to is relatively limited and on top of
that the documentation for that site is
is inert I can't go from the
documentation on their site to some
working code very easily there's a big
contact ship when jumping between those
two things one other thing is traversing
graphs so quick question who can
traverse graphs I think humans and
computers can both traverse graphs and
of those two I would say that computers
are generally better and so this is one
thing I'm personally really excited
about this is an extension to the
graphical Explorer graphical Explorer
and the idea here is this doc panel over
here is great if I search for pull
requests I see okay somewhere in here
there is a github pull request with all
these fields
but the problem is I actually don't know
how to navigate to this node from the
root right from all those top-level
fields I don't know how to get to go I
know what I want but I know how to get
there and so it would be nice if I could
just kind of come in here and say well I
know there's an email field somewhere go
figure out where that is and have a
computer walk through the entire graph
for me figuring out where that is and
then I say oh yeah somewhere inside of
Dropbox I wanted that so if I click on
that then it's gonna go ahead and build
up the entire graph or the entire
structure all the ancestors to get there
and if you think about what a difference
that is in experiencing AP is where I
come to your API looking for either some
effect or some data and I just say I
don't know where it is but this is what
I want and then it's able to actually
generate an entire query or mutation
that will get me exactly what I want
that is night and day difference in
terms of onboarding another one is multi
AP is integration is a topic that is
near and dear to my heart and I hate it
integration sucks it's generally never
very fun but I think that graph QL
actually has something huge to offer
here it's actually why I originally got
interested in graph QL because I had to
integrate 20 or 30 different api's and
the example I want to show here is how
thorough so show of hands
who has heard of Hustler who has used it
and who has used it in production
okay so handful of people the short
pitch for Hazara is that it's like
firebase except it's on Postgres it's
standard graph QL and it's entirely open
source I don't know exactly what their
business model is I think they're a
bunch of chumps to give this all away
but it is amazing I'm really really
enthusiastic about these folks but
basically what they give you is you can
point Hazara at any Postgres database
and it will give you a real-time
graphical API that is absolutely superb
Postgres is great and graph QL is great
how server makes them great together
but one thing we've been working with
them together on
is joining multiple schemas together and
what an example of that here where I
have a console here so this is the
historic console and I have a Postgres
table called user and so you can see
here it's exposed a user node here we're
using the Explorer to build this out and
what I'm saying is all right well on
this user I'm gonna get their first name
their last name in the Striped customer
ID and stripe customer ID is a foreign
key and foreign keys are terrible the
only reason you ever have a foreign key
for a thing is to get to the thing and
you as a programmer in this scenario can
query into Postgres you can get a stripe
customer ID pluck it off and then you
manually imperative Li make a call into
stripes API and pull out the data that
you need on a stripe customer so that's
a lot of work to actually integrate
these two different data sources
well what Howser has been able to do is
actually have these things called remote
joints where you can bring in any remote
graph QL schema and it will introspect
it just like we saw before hand and it
will merge those two schemas together
but more importantly you can come in
here and actually add a derived field so
you can see I've already pulled in one
graph and so now what I'm gonna do is
add a remote relationship and I'm gonna
say on the user table I want to create a
field called stripe customer
I don't want stripe customer ID and once
the stripe customer and this is actually
gonna come from one graph and this is
what the connection looks like so just
like the Explorer I'm gonna go in there
and say oh it comes from stripe its
customer and the ID parameter is going
to come from the stripe customer ID row
on the table so I that's done I'm gonna
go back to graphical I'm going to get
rid of the stripe customer ID and now
what I'm gonna do is actually just join
in to stripe and start pulling data out
from there so I'm hitting my data store
and it's reaching out and pulling in
data about all this customers from
stripe transparently that level of
integration
is hours or days of work and we can do
that in seconds with graph QL and remote
schema stitching like this so I think
multi api's is phenomenal in particular
if I have a graph QAPI and you have a
graph QAPI and suddenly the integration
looks like that right it's going to get
done a lot faster and I'm going to feel
a lot happier as a developer and I would
actually say you know stripe has an
amazing API they have great
documentation they have great client
libraries but if you were to compare the
experience that we just saw with Hazara
to even their great node JavaScript API
is it's not even a comparison it's so
much more work to pull in data from
stripe as a library then it is from
stripe as an int respectable graph so
one other one that I really like is that
again we're talking about useful context
and I think the autocomplete inside of
vs code goes a long way there right so
just like before this is effectively
graphical inside of the S code so if I'm
looking through the Salesforce API I can
come here and each step along the way I
can actually just kind of autocomplete
my way through here and get all the
fields I need and yes it's a bit like
graphical you know the we haven't put
the Explorer in here yet but this idea
is like by the time you're here you're
probably familiar with it but this is a
pretty radical idea I think being able
to autocomplete your way through remote
schemas is crazy
well at least for me and then one other
thing I want to show is that graph QL
goes everywhere part of the reason that
I built that bash exporter it wasn't
just for the lols it wasn't just a joke
but we wanted to show people and to
encourage people to think that graph QL
doesn't just exist on the front end we
wanted to it's right now so tightly
associated with the front end that
people kind of limited there but
actually graphic gooooal can go to lots
and lots
of different places and importantly
developers are not the only people who
can consume graph QL and build things in
fact the largest platforming program in
the world is Excel something like 650
million users and so what we did is we
built a version of the graphical
Explorer so you can see over here it's
rendering slightly different it's not
the actual field names it's showing some
of the bit more human readable but you
can point this at any graph QL server
and it will introspect it and now as an
Excel user I can start pulling in data
so I'm gonna pull in data from
Salesforce here and what I want to do is
actually generate a revenue forecast and
the revenue forecast is going to come
from data from Salesforce I'm gonna pull
down a list of my opportunities I'm
gonna get their size I'm gonna get their
probability and I'm also going to
reverse over to the owner of it and I
don't care that I'm traversing over the
API I'm just expressing the data I want
and now that I have the data inside of
Excel I can make magic happen right
Excel is like this magical escape hatch
where you know managers and
non-technical people can actually be
incredibly independent the challenge is
getting the data in there so just kind
of going through here and once I have
this built up like Excel gives me this
crazy UI so I can say well maybe I want
to see how Daniel is doing on the
expected revenue forecast or I only want
to see the clothes opportunities like
Excel actually generates a really good
UI this is a really nice experience as
long as you can get the data inside of
Excel and think of how many times you
know you've had a manager say something
like hey I need a list of all the users
who signed up for the past two months so
I can do whatever analysis and then you
go and you generate a CSV and you send
it over to them and they said well
actually I also need their email and the
first name and by the way can you sort
it by you know number of stars or
something like that and the thing is
developers in that case are actually
being like they're a poor interpreter
for the Excel users
desires but if we can just make it so
Excel users are independent where if you
have that hysteria in points with all of
your API is behind it suddenly give them
a readout only access to it and they can
pull in all the data they need and
they'll be fine
one other area where I think graphic
excels that isn't often looked at is
server-to-server communication so what
we do here is build a subscription and
it's gonna go into NPM and what it's
going to say is anytime a package is
published on NPM I want to pull out
these fields I want to pull out the name
of the package I want to know the
Downloads last month and also if this is
associated with a github repository then
I wanted to go over into github and I
want to get a list of issues and I'll
about the first ten of them and I want
to know maybe just the open issues
I'll get the total count so now I have a
subscription that anytime NPM is going
to publish anything it's going to give
me some information from upm and some
information from github and what I want
to say is I want you to just deliver
this rather than delivering it over
WebSockets which is where subscriptions
are traditionally used I can say I want
you to deliver this to my server so you
know wherever it might be
and I'll show you a list of what we have
as an example so come in here and this
is the query actually running live and
it's just been delivering every package
that's been published to NPM and if i
refresh it should 27 seconds ago so you
can see it's just pulling out the exact
data it needs and so for asynchronous
server-to-server communication graph QL
actually really excels because you can I
say here are the events that I can offer
you these are all routes into the graph
somehow and you can figure out the query
that you want to make whenever something
happens and just tell me where to
deliver it so incredibly powerful
off so we talked a lot about off so far
off socks it's one of those things that
I think should just go away and I think
the way you make it go away is by
building it deeply into your your API
and so I want to show a login example
where I'm going to come in here and let
me go ahead and clear this out and I'm
gonna query into stripe and you'll
notice that this button popped up right
here and the reason it did that is we
normalize the off missing error across
all of the services and so you can see
here in under errors and extensions we
have a type here of off missing off and
in the service and so what that means is
there's one single function that checks
the results of every single result as it
comes back from the server and says were
there any errors of type off missing if
so what was the service and it pops up a
button asking the user to sign in so now
as a developer I don't have to think
about that at all right I just have one
bit of middleware that handles that for
my entire application and this actually
extends to things like progressive
authorization so progressive
authorization is what you should do as a
developer who cares about your users
experience what you should do is say you
know whenever a user logs into your
application you should only ask for the
bare minimum permission so we're bare
minimum scopes that you need in order to
satisfy them at that moment and then
progressively as they do things through
your app you can textually ask for that
specific permission but this is such a
pain as a developer because you have to
remember what permissions do I have
right now what does this require and
then contextual II ask accordingly so
what you get is you sign into an app and
it says hey I need these 20 permissions
and you know either take it or leave it
and I think progressive off is the right
thing to do it's just very difficult but
can we make it just go away and I think
the way we do that is by annotating our
schema just with some directives and
we're saying some metadata here we're
saying hey this field requires these
scopes
and now whenever a developer asks for a
field that they don't have access to we
have a normalized error which is just
insufficient off and this is the scope
that you actually needed for that field
and so now what happens is as a
developer I program as though I have
access to everything all right I just
make API calls and then there's just one
bit of middleware that checks the
results of that and says hey that thing
I just tried to do then I was I missing
any scopes and if so I'll go ahead and
ask the user for that and now the user
is contextually prompted user that
button you just clicked
turns out we need send permissions on
Gmail right so now the user gets their
best experience and the developer gets
their best experience and it's this
really nice way of making all these hard
problems go away while still improving
the experience for everyone and then
another question we get is how do you
implement off so implementing off on the
graphical side is still up in the air
in particular authentication is
relatively easy right it's just who are
you but authorization has been more
difficult
right because authorization entails what
are you allowed to do and what you're
allowed to do oftentimes depends on
facts about you right are you part of my
github org are you the owner of this
playlist have you ever committed to my
repository whatever it might be there
are certain facts about you I need to
know in order to generalize your
authorization but if we have a graph
that knows where these facts are then we
can actually build a pretty cool way of
encoding all of that so this is off
Guardian this is not open source but the
idea would generalize to any other API
and what this does is actually just
introspect on the graph QL API and
generates a UI like this so what I'm
gonna do is whenever a user logs in to
any service so github egghead Spotify
whatever I'm gonna run all of these
rules and if any of the rules succeed
then I'm going to actually execute this
predicate so for example on github if
this user is a member of an organization
called one graph then what I'm gonna do
is on asura I'm gonna set a default role
of admin
and this is going to generate a JW or a
job for me and I'm gonna now go ahead
and log in to github and now because I
am a member of one graph you can see
this is a preview of what that job is
going to look like but what I also want
to do is say on github when a user is
logged in so a login status is true then
I want to set a value of user ID to
built-in value and they're a bunch of
built-in values that we know about like
github user ID you can see here that's
that looks good and I'm gonna do one
more so I do user dot login and it's a
built-in value of the github login and
we can do more so I can say on
salesforce whenever this person has an
email with a domain that's equal to one
graph com then I'll net Liffe I add a
roll of sales so our net liffe I you can
restrict access to different endpoints
based off of a net worth I jot and so
with this I'm actually able to encode a
ton of rules about my authorization in
one central place all right I can
actually look at these rules as a human
being and say this looks right for the
permissions that should be available and
then based off of that we're able to go
in to just do one graph
so this is what it actually looks like
whenever it comes time to embed this
inside of your API so this is using a
polo server and we're simply saying that
in order to access the account balance
you have to have a roll of admin so over
here I can also as a human being
glance at this description of our API
and make sure that all these rules
actually seem consistent so we're
boiling down something that has
traditionally been very very imperative
and scattered across a bunch of code
into small siloed bits where we can
analyze the rules for authorization and
the requirements for accessing data
separately so and then at the end we end
up with one single jobs that will work
with our Apollo server it'll work with
ha Sura
and it will work with net Lafayette
cetera all right so big jump here I'm
going to now talk about docks so
documentation is another area that I
think is very difficult
Rebecca talked about this in her talk
that actually very many graphical
developers think of graph hill as being
self documenting rights because the
tooling is so nice and it's in
respectable and you have all these you
know digital explorers and whatnot users
will just figure it out but this isn't
fatica lis not the case a determined one
may but human oriented documentation
still has a very strong place right
being able to understand the examples
and the overall structure of your API
but Doc's have a number of problems and
the first of one first of them is that
Doc's lie right there are lies damn lies
and API documentation and that's not
because developers are bad people
necessarily there are lots of different
reasons right maybe you wrote the
documentation and you never had time to
actually test it out or you wrote it and
it works but the implementation actually
drifted off and now the documentation is
outdated there are a number of api's
that are like that that I've been doing
with it's very common so well
documentation has a really nice place it
is actually also a double-edged sword
because it's easy for it to become a
negative where I go and I copy and paste
your example thinking it's going to work
and actually hit a wall so in this case
we have a github repository example
saying hey if you want to clear your git
repositories here's how you do it but
you'll notice that there's the missing
key here and so if someone were to paste
this in it wouldn't work
so here's a proposed solution what you
can do is connect to a little service to
your github repository scan all of the
markdown files where your documentation
exists pull out any of the graph QL code
blocks and then verify that the docs
that the query inside of there is
actually valid for your current schema
and then you can do this on every build
right you simply run this as a here's my
schema here's my github repository are
there any examples which are now invalid
based off of the schema I'm about to
push and then you get something like
this or says hey there is actually no
argument called first maybe meant first
and now you will never break an example
without knowing it but once you have
those examples you can actually take
them to more interesting places in
particular you can take them for example
into graphical where if I'm looking at a
type over on the right hand side it can
say hey here are all of the examples
that actually reference this type or
this field and I can start to explore
that much better than trying to navigate
to that like we saw earlier with the the
search and this is even better than
search because this is a example that's
going to have some human documentation
that says something like hey if you're
trying to list your recently purchased
domains here's how you do it and then
you can make it really easy in fact for
your users to submit examples so this is
a little graphical plugin where it'll
take whatever you have working in there
and you think other people might like
this i might want to share it with them
and what i will do is submit it and now
that example will be tested on every see
i run to make sure that it isn't being
broken without your knowledge and now
your users can contribute examples and
actually grow your documentation for you
and then the last problem is that docs
are dead things they're kind of inert
you write them and they stay that way
until you go and you update them and
actually think that you can combine
these techniques with some analytics and
you can say what i want to know is for
all of the new users who sign up in the
past two weeks what are the most popular
fields show me like you know 90% of them
hits these three fields and the computer
can't tell you what those fields mean it
doesn't know the semantics of that but
you do you know say hey i don't know
here's the general shape what is
and you can say oh this is a user who's
trying to get a list of the recently
purchased domains say okay we'll add a
description you say well you know here's
a description of this example if you're
trying to do this and bla bla bla bla
bla and now that becomes an example that
will go inside of your Docs and your
Doc's will actually respond to the
behavior statuses right so now whenever
you're new users come and they start
accessing different parts of your API
that you haven't documented quite as
well there aren't examples you can be
notified if the general structure
changes and so now your documentation is
actually responding to what users are
doing and it's asking you and saying hey
I recognize new behavior what is this
you know document this so that I can
push this out to the doc site not only
that we can actually sort the examples
based off of the popularity right by the
the demographics of the clients or just
over on the overall popular usage so
this is a open source app that we built
for this called graph QL code X and this
will take in any graph qaul schema and
generate an SEO bull site that's
incredibly fast and will allow you to
search across the entire thing so just
for reference one graphs schema at this
point I think is probably the largest
graph QL API that's something like 35 or
40 megabytes of JSON uncompressed so
when we do here I search for pull
requests you can see it's super fast and
I can come in here and immediately pops
open and I can see github pull requests
in other fields and I can see here's an
example of it it shows me in line but
maybe I want to look at it and as I
hover over it it will give me all these
fields and I can view it in graphical if
I want you can see that it has the
shortened example there this was
actually submitted from inside of
graphical and so this is a way of
actually taking your API making it
searchable indexable easily usable for
lots of different clients and now you
have this kind of full cycle where
people can come submit examples it'll
show up in here
you always have up-to-date documentation
anything in here is guaranteed to work
in terms of the fields being correct and
whatnot
so this is you know graph QL codex
should be open-source soon now yes and
it also produce an automated changelog
like github changelog okay so one other
ninety degree turn is persisted queries
show of hands who knows about persisted
query so sort of them okay for the two
people who has used them in production
okay so we have two people alright so
the idea behind persisted queries is a
little bit different the idea is simply
that rather than sending over an entire
graph Kuehl query at run time this is
actually going to become a dev or build
time step where whenever we're running a
web pack build for production it's going
to extract all the graph QL tags and
it's going to send them to the server
it's gonna say hey server I'm going to
need this query in the future I want you
to store it for me and the server will
store it in some fashion and it will
return an ID for that query and now
inside of your source code that graph
Gale gets replaced with just a call to
that with that doc ID or that's a query
ID so you're going to be sending over
much much smaller queries to the server
at runtime but more importantly this
allows the developer to have that same
experience where they're kind of you
know adding whatever fields they want to
explore in the graph and they have full
control but those queries become baked
in at Build time so now the end users
are not able to add and remove fields
willy-nilly right so you have this nice
locked down implementation and so this
is really nice for preventing denial
service attacks for example where at
Build time for example Twitter with
TweetDeck what they do is at Build time
they persist all of their queries none
of it is available for the public to hit
and during that persisting phase it
actually costs the query and it says how
expensive do I expect this query to be
and if it's too expensive it actually
rejects it and tells the developer you
need to break this up into smaller
queries so now the operations people are
much
you're right because they can bound the
amount of pressure that they're going to
be under at any given time the developer
is still happy because they can go
through and explore all the API is they
want and then the end user is none the
wiser but in particular it also allows
you it gives you a wonderful cache key
right cache and graph QL has been a hot
topic for cystic queries give you an
amazing cache key it's just the document
ID if it's a public query and if it's an
authenticated query it's the document ID
and the auth token hash so now you have
an exact hash where you can say this
should be available for five minutes
and one thing that I'm really excited
about that I think is an unexplored area
is you're actually able to attach
metadata so in one graphs case we attach
off to persisted queries so let me show
you what that looks like so I'm gonna
come over here and this is a mutation
that is going to send an email to Jesse
who kindly organized all of this graph
kill track and this is going to require
permission from Gmail and I consider my
gmail to be a pretty sensitive data
source so what I'm gonna do is create a
token that has access to that so it's
called too hard for API days I'm gonna
add access to Gmail and we'll come in
here authenticate and Google's like are
you sure I mean that's that's pretty
risky now I'm gonna give it access to
all that stuff and just for good measure
we'll throw in github here and so now
this one token is gonna have access to
Gmail and github would you Spotify and
just for the heck of it we'll do Twitter
all right so now we have one token which
has access to a tremendous amount of
sensitive data for me some create that
token now what I'm gonna do is come over
to this mutation and I'm gonna persist
it so I'm gonna go ahead and paste it in
and what we do is it's going to persist
in such a way
that it's parameterised so I've hard
coded the subject of this and I've hard
coded - it's - so no one can edit this
after I have persisted it but they can
provide a body variable that's the only
thing that they can parameterize so what
I do is use I'm gonna persist it with
this auth token I'm gonna say the user
is allowed to provide body so go ahead
and persist this and now it gives me a
little curl example so I'm gonna run
this in curl and I'll say hi from
onstage and there we go
this is a curl that will actually send
an email to Jessie and it has it's doing
it with a token that is incredibly
sensitive so of course what I'm gonna do
is tweet this whoops let's do it on gist
because of Twitter is crazy URL
shortening okay so we'll create a secret
gist and now on Twitter anyone is going
to be able to run that curl command and
send Jessie an email from me but the
subject is going to be lockdown and the
two is going to be lockdown and I'm not
worried about that the sensitivity of
the auth token because the only thing
that they have access to is that one
mutation and they can only pass in a
body variable so I'm able to lock it
down in a really nice way and in
particular I mean that's a fun example
but I want to show you a real world
example so this is a open source
blogging app that we built that we are
basically terrible at blogging and so we
want to make it as easy as possible to
just push out quick snippets quick
updates so we call this change log and
you can see here there are just some
updates on what we're doing as one graph
to see lots of different posts and
whatnot this is actually driven
from github API so if I open up the
github API over here and I go ahead and
put them side-by-side you can see that
if I come in here on this repository
which is one graph changelog it's open
and you went from here and open it so
I'm gonna say hi from onstage and I'll
go ahead and submit that and if i
refresh over here within a few seconds I
should pop up what I'm gonna do instead
though is go ahead and try to react to
one of these and say hey I like this
what it's doing right now before I
logged in is it's actually making live
queries to github using my co-founders
github off token so whenever someone
isn't logged in they're still able to
access the exact data on github that we
need to run this site so we're able to
pull that all in securely and
efficiently with crafty well without
worrying about exposing everything and
you'll notice that this is not coming up
here because anyone can open an issue on
a repository but only admins for
repository can add a label to come in
and add that in and we refresh should
see it pop up in just a few seconds and
in the meantime what I'm gonna do is
come into here so view form on stage and
I'll add a comment and we'll add that in
so you can see the comment pops up
immediately
and if I like it and I had some
emoticons works perfectly and now what
I'm gonna do is remove the publish tag
because my co-founder hates this demo
because that actually goes live on our
blog update yeah so now it's missing
post which is great and perfect there we
go
so that's open source you can use that
for anything users real lame persisted
queries and rate the hood so it's a real
world example of building a product
that's meaningful based off of
persistent queries all right so that's
kind of the end of my demos and I want
to wrap up by talking a little bit about
the future kind of the near future and
what I think will happen longer-term so
in particular I think graph QL lends
itself really nicely to this virtuous
cycle where because of the introspective
of nature
we can build great tooling and this
enables your developers to actually
explore your API really really easily
they can in experiment and then move
from that experiment into a useful
context very quickly but then you as an
API provider can run analytics on it and
you can actually analyze how are people
using our API and based off of that you
can create new examples new
documentation and you can optimize your
API you can say that oh it looks like
people are trying to do this in a
convoluted way maybe we could redesign
our API a little bit so it would be
easier to do that and that will enable
and then our you know consumers to be
able to explore more easily now with
deep analytics you can do some pretty
crazy things so in particular I think
you can do like for new users who have
not used your API you can do something
like an auto classification what we want
to do here is make it so that whenever
someone comes to our API even without an
account they can start hitting our API
they won't get real data we want to get
them just dummy data but the way we're
gonna do this in a way that is actually
meaningful is by watching our production
traffic every time some data goes over
for a field say first name or email or
whatever it might be
we're gonna take that value and we're
just gonna send it to a classifier some
low-level machine learning thing and
I'll just ask it hey what does this look
like because graph qo will tell you the
concrete's type of a field that it's a
string but it won't tell you any
semantic information about it especially
not in a way that a computer can help
you but classifiers are very good and so
we just pass it through when you say hey
what does this look like and we'll say
hey this looks like a first name it
looks like a full name a zip code
whatever it might be and you just store
that probabilistic that statistical
information somewhere and now one of our
user comes to your API page and they
haven't actually signed up yet
you can start generating incredibly
realistic
data for them to actually build their
application and where this is really
useful is for those of you who have a
longer sales cycle where the customer
wants to actually start building
integration today but they may not
actually sign a contract for another six
weeks and so what you can tell them is
they can confidently build their UI
build the front and build their
integration on top of you knowing that
once that account is flipped on
everything will work exactly as it did
when they were building on your mocked
data and not only that but you can
actually offer them something that no
one else can which is you can say
alright once you've built your UI we'll
break it for you we will actually fuzz
your UI where you said all right I built
with a certain expectation of names in
mind but the problem with that is users
are unpredictable it's hard to predict
what names are going to look like in
production and so you can say I built it
with you know my friend's name is mind
but now show me what it looks like with
the top thousand common English names
just fuzz my UI show me Chinese show me
right-to-left break my UI and I'll just
show it we render it ten thousand times
over and show me what actually moves in
a visual diff as I changed these
parameters and now I can design with all
of these use cases in mind and actually
test it out rather than waiting for it
to go to production a user to hit a bug
and then report it to us if we're lucky
another fun one is because graph kill
has this idea of operations where you
can persist more than one operation at a
time and then whenever you're calling it
you actually just specify which of these
operations you want you can kind of
build these really powerful endpoints
that they can do a lot and oftentimes
what you want to do is say well the data
from this query is actually used in the
data for this mutation so I just kind of
want to run them in this order so what
I've done here is put together a couple
of operations and what this is going to
do is whenever I text Twilio it's going
to use that webhook to trigger this
process
and it's going to actually see he's
gonna take the body of an SMS and it's
going to try to purchase it as a domain
is then going to create a github
repository with that and a net loss
eyesight and deploy something so and
then most importantly so let me turn
this on and turn on my volume it's gonna
get us jammed so in particular let's
look at this and let's see what be a
good one API days on stage comm yeah mm
agent so I'm gonna send this over no
Twilio is very kindly going to receive
that it's going to send it over to one
graph it's going to trigger one of those
queries to see if a domain is available
if it is it's then going to go ahead and
purchase it after it purchases it is
going to create a github repository it's
then going to create an edifice site
it's going to start playing my Spotify
player so let's go ahead and go to
repositories so you can see I got
win-win-win playing now I'm getting
jammed and now I'm gonna create an API
days on stage already and now whenever I
come in here I can go to the API days
net Lefroy and within a few minutes
should have deployed a new site so you
know if you're ever wondering if there's
a series of things that you want to
automate graph QL is incredibly amenable
to that right because of the way that
you can express each of your intents as
an operation that's isolated very
quickly and then being able to just
thread them together so you can actually
express an entire pipeline of things so
let's see how that ax fire is doing for
us and we'll come back to that so it
looks like they're busy building our
site all right another one is uh you can
do deep performance monitoring so I
think graph kill is much more amenable
to this than many other systems in
particular you can get the performance
and timing the error rates you can get
audit logs the bytes per field
you can prevent breaking schemas very
easily in particular this one is I'm
excited about because you can deprecated
old fields that you don't want anymore
and you can identify the specific
clients who have ever accessed this
field and then reach out to them and say
hey we want to get you off of this and
we're gonna help you we know exactly you
know who is affected by this here is a
transformer that's going to change that
query that has this old field into the
new one automatically you'll still have
to fix your code that reads it but will
rewrite all of your deprecated queries
automatically and one thing you can do
here actually is just never break your
clients so in particular graph fuel has
this idea of no versions and that means
that developers are going to be sad
ultimately the developers who provide an
API because you are going to make
mistakes as you actually build out your
API and what you want to be able to do
is correct those mistakes but people are
already relying on it so what you can do
instead is never break them and never
deprecated a field what you want to do
is just create an entirely new schema
what you can do is look at how stripe
does it where stripe has hundreds and
hundreds of versions of their API which
is insane right even as good as they are
that's still insane but the way they do
this is every endpoint has a type for
the request and the response and
whenever a request comes in whenever you
add a new endpoint you write a migration
for that request type from the old type
to the new one and what stripe will do
is actually run the migrations for that
request until it reaches the most modern
version it will then execute that
endpoint and get a result that results
will then run through all the down
migrations to get back to what it should
have been for that API so now they
maintain one API but their users are
able to hit hundreds of different
versions of that API you can do the same
thing with graph key well when I'm
really excited about this gdpr
which is not a thing I would have said a
while ago but I think actually there's a
lot of really powerful things you can do
here so in particular just like with
authorization and often too
you can annotate your scheme and say hey
this is PII this is HIPPA this is you
know Coppa or GPR and what you want to
do is now this actually just like the
authorization gdpr enforcement can be
handled orthogonal link just by some
middle work and say hey you don't have
access to this go away
but even if you do have access to this
what I'm gonna do is keep a log I'm
gonna say that alright I see that you're
accessing this object which has gdpr
data associated with it and I'm going to
insert the ID field even if you didn't
ask for it and whenever the server comes
back with its results I'll go ahead and
pluck it out you don't want it but I'll
keep it
what I'm gonna do is say that this
client ID which had access accessed a
graphical object of this type with this
ID and these fields and now if you ever
get hacked if there's ever a data breach
on your side I can actually calculate
backwards the exact envelope of exposure
I know the exact objects the exact
people and the exact data that is
potentially exposed instead of doing
that manually and emailing 15 million
users maybe it turns out to be a hundred
one thing that might be useful we have a
version that's internally we are looking
to open source it at some point it's a
way of actually helping people get on
board with graphical api's by deriving
the ground truth from their existing API
and the way this works is as a rust HTTP
clients or proxy or as an internet or
sidecar plugin and what it does is
analyze all the incoming requests and it
looks at the hostname the path the body
and the output and it tracks novelty
over time
what it wants to know is say have I seen
this host before have I seen this
endpoint I've seen this response before
but it always had a name key with a
string and now that name is gone that
must mean that this name key is a
knowable string and it tracks novelty
over time and over the number of
requests and eventually there have been
tens of thousands of requests and weeks
have gone by
it's seen everything right head is
actually documented the ground truth of
your REST API and then you can use
heuristics like any field that ends in
ID you set that value aside and you look
at the end points any in point that
returns an ID of that value and it
suggests a link between it if it's a
UUID it very strongly suggests a link
and you can actually derive the graph
structure from this automatically and
then generate a graph QL server that
will be about 80% of the way there it
won't be entirely idiomatic but it will
cover the exact ground truth of your API
in fact we've had partners who come to
us and they want us to be the graphical
front for them and they say oh well we
have open API specs this will be easy
and we've learned to just say don't even
worry about it just install this thing
because we need to know the ground truth
rather than what you think the truth is
so that's a self-contained binary we
want it to be open source and run
on-premise and whatnot
one last one I'll end with is graphical
dr so this is one that we want to
encourage people to basically analyze
your queries and teach you best
practices so in this case you would run
it and would say hey I notice that you
haven't named your operation and will
give you a GUI to do that it would say
that do you think you might want to
parameterize you might want to change
this hard-coded value if so well be the
the name of that and we'll go ahead and
change it for you automatically so
basically something to help new users
get over learning all of the best
practices so in summary I think graph
queue itself offers just huge benefits
out of the box but the tooling that we
can build on top of it means that the
experience is just night and day
difference right we've seen that like
data scientists and managers can get
access to it developers can generate
entire applications etc and I think that
this is important because it goes back
to time to initial success frequency and
super powers I think graph QL gives you
all those tremendously and you want to
basically pick a standard that offers
you all of that out of the box rather
than you having to reinvent it every
single time
so the contents of your API is what you
should be focusing on not the tooling
and so I would caution you with like I
think all these things are really
impressive today but they won't be very
soon they'll just be table stakes right
our tooling the all the stuff we've
shown you is used in tons and tons of
different places now github is using a
gatsby's using it 8 bases using it it's
everywhere this will be table sticks if
you don't have this you'll be seen as
laughable right if your API requires me
to do more work than that Hofstra
integration I showed you that's insane
so just ask yourself how is your API
going to fit into a world where you're
not able to take advantage of all of
this tooling so I'll give away 5 of the
graph QL books to the people who ask the
best questions so if you have any
questions about today or you want any
demos or anything happy to give away the
five best graph to all books and or grab
coffee so I think that's it thank you
[Applause]
I think I feel steam coming out of my
ears there's always so much content
whatever you spin so we are actually
quite over on time would it be okay if
we moved those questions to the Twitter
format were made to be something a
little more available so if you have a
question tweet Adam and then he'll pick
what his five favorite and and get you
get you a book so wrapping it up we're
actually over so I think they're gonna
be kicking us out of the room here
pretty quickly I do want to have one
correction onion one of your slides
you'd said that I organized the track
and Jonathan actually put together all
the speaks all the talk so a big
applause with Jonathan I just I just
gave English where English was helpful
and so that was basically the only thing
I did so big thank you to you for
getting all the speakers and it was a
really great great day graph QL is still
developing so next year could be you on
stage so explore something discover
something learn something you want to
teach to everybody else and submit the
call for talks
we have graph QL talks happening at all
the API events this coming year so
there's lots of room so I think that's
basically it actually one more time
thank you for your talk that's amazing
and we'll see you guys next year I'll
walk
[Applause]